The teleportation corner
In Japan
Sernin
In Germany
In Korea
In Blood
In Qías
So, headset erstmal entknotet, oh Null Zuschauer, Twitch ist mal wieder richtig, ah jetzt geht's,
wollte ich halt sagen Twitch ist wieder high speed hier.
Ich kann noch mal kurz was gucken, Settings, Output, alles gut, alles richtig.
Vielleicht bisschen laut.
So Leute, ich hab gedacht ich mach einfach mal den Stream an, kann ja nichts schaden.
Um euch jetzt mal ne Runde zu schocken, oft nicht alle wieder wach, Chef ruft an, was
war das für ein Piep, nein das ist der Teams Sound, das ist der Teams Sound, alternativ
hätt ich auch noch ICQ zu bieten, man verwende Teams, es verwenden gefühlt 90% der Menschheit
Teams mittlerweile, also ich denke nicht das ist so ein, kann man Teams den Sound austauschen,
das müsste ich eigentlich auch mal machen, das blumm geht mir richtig auf den Zack, ihr
benutzt Rocket Chat und was, was ist BBB, erklär mal, was ist BBB, ich stell mir da
glaube ich irgendwas falsches drunter vor, ah ok, Big Blue Button hab ich nicht gehört,
Sarex, da hab ich jetzt nicht dran gedacht, das war mal klar, dass irgendwer mit sowas
jetzt gleich wieder um die Ecke kommt, Gachibass, und selbst wenn in der heutigen Zeit ist es
überhaupt nicht verwerflich an sowas zu denken.
Erzähl mal was witziges aus meinem Alltag, also stell dir mal vor, ich hatte letztens
um genau zu sein war das vor zwei Tagen hat ein neuer Datenbank Experte bei uns angefangen,
und das erste was ich von ihm gehört hab ist die Frage was ist eigentlich GitHub, da hört
man in letzter Zeit so viel von, oder ne, da hört man ja seit zwei bis drei Jahren so
viel von, er hat da noch nie was von mitbekommen, außer dass er da manchmal irgendwelche Sachen
runterladen muss, aber was ist, warum benutzt man das überhaupt und wofür ist das da?
Da hab ich mir gedacht, was, wie kannst du Datenbank Experte sein, ok, das wurde natürlich
auf Twitter, also auf Twitter war das, ne das ist kein Entwickler, ne ne, aber sag mal so,
moin Michael5 Spieler, sagen wir es mal, so, also nicht so, sondern so, also sagen wir
es mal so, du bist als Datenbank Admin, beziehungsweise Datenbank Experte oder DBA, wie sich das ja
dann abkürzt, du bist jetzt kein Entwickler, du musst jetzt nicht das Git auswendig kennen
und alle möglichen Workflow, Geschichten, was man da so macht, also es ist egal, du
musst auch, du musst doch nicht wissen wie man übers Revlog fünf Comets zurück und
sonst was oder wie man beispielsweise Interactive Rebase macht, musst du nicht wissen, aber,
aber ganz im Ernst, auch als DBA solltest du ein bisschen aktuelle Geschehnisse in
der IT Welt im Hinterkopf haben oder im Blick, im Blick ist besser, solltest du im Blick
haben und da ist es nur einfach so, dass die letzten Jahre über kein Weg an Git und GitHub
vorbei führt, das muss man auch als DBA mitkriegen, in DBA ist ja im Endeffekt meistens ein Linux
Admin, der Ahnung von Datenbanken hat, also insofern sollte man das schon mitbekommen
haben und das hat mich tatsächlich geschockt, dass der da keine Ahnung von hatte, es ist
eh erstaunlich, also wir hatten mal einen externen Consultant, Experten, was auch immer
eingekauft, der sollte, ich weiß, ich erzähl euch jetzt nicht zum zwanzigsten Mal die Geschichte
von dem Typ, der unser Storage kaputt gemacht hat, da hab ich ja sogar schon ein Video drüber
gemacht, nee, wir müssen es ja nicht übertreiben, ich zeig euch auch was anderes, und zwar
wir hatten mal einen Experten, ich weiß gar nicht mehr genau wofür der da war, der sollte,
ich weiß es gar nicht mehr, irgendwas im Linux Bereich auf jeden Fall sollte der das machen
und der hat ohne Scheiß einen Monat, das ist jetzt kein Witz Leute, ich schwör, der hat
einen Monat gebraucht sein Notebook einzurichten, mit Linux drauf installiert und das soll ein
Linux Consultant, also jetzt mal im Ernst, was ist denn mit denen los, gut, nach dem Monat
hat er sich dann auch vom Acker gemacht, hat festgestellt, das ist hier nix bei uns, aber
trotzdem, also ich bin, ich hab da ja zwei Theorien, entweder leiden die Leute alle an
maßloser Selbstüberschätzung oder, und das ist wahrscheinlicher, die Vermittlungstypen
organisieren die Lebensläufe so krass, dass man eigentlich gar nicht mehr auf sich auf
was verlassen kann, schon das neue Update Refs in Git 2.3 gesehen, nee, zeig mal her,
was gibt's denn Shit Neues, was Minus Minus Update Refs, ship new options to rebase, call
Minus Minus Update Refs, that knows how to perform these updates for you, let's try same
example again, was, äh, das hab ich jetzt nicht gecheckt, was, soweit, ok, ja, versteh
ich, ok, Datei editieren, versteh ich auch, adden, versteh ich auch, committen, versteh
ich auch, Moment, was ist denn, wait a minute, Git, Git commit Minus Minus fix up, was ist
denn das, das kenn ich noch gar nicht, Zack, wissen wir, haha, Atlassian, lull, mach das,
was macht das, commit, das gibt's seit 2018, hab ich noch nie gesehen, commit fix up in
autos, ach so, das macht für dich automatisch eine commit message, fix das und das, ok,
ja, naja, kann man machen, so, und jetzt kommt Update Refs, ich check's, ich hab's immer
noch nicht gecheckt, ok, Git Update Refs, hast du schon Overwatch 2 gespielt, nein, ich
hab's, ich, ich hab jetzt den Blogpost nicht kapiert, ehrlich gesagt, was wollen die mir
sagen, jaja, ich hab das gelesen, aber ich hab den überhaupt nicht gesehen, dass der
in diesem GIF Update Refs verwendet hätte, hat er doch gar nicht, oder, oder kommt das
oben drüber, das war, wo, wo, wo ist das in dem GIF, wo macht er ein Rebase, ich seh's
nicht, fix up, ok, ach da, da macht er ein Rebase, ach so, ok, jetzt hab ich's gesehen,
ja, und dadurch, dass du vorhin Git commit fix up verwendet hast, checkt er, dass er
diese Comets zusammenfassen soll, oder was, oder, oder, weil ansonsten ist, ansonsten
hab ich noch nicht so genau gecheckt, zumindest neue Git Options sind immer POG, muss ich
mir mal angucken, er ist noch in der Que, nee, ich hab kein Overwatch 2 bis jetzt gekauft,
ich warte jetzt erstmal bis es funktioniert, ich guck's mir auf jeden Fall die nächsten
Tage mal an, noch cooler wär's, wenn ich vielleicht die ein oder andere Leute, mit
denen ich früher gespielt hab, da mal reaktivieren könnte für 1, 2 Duo Aktionen, er rebast
alle darauf basierenden Branches gleich mit, dann ist das doch nicht so tolle, ganz ehrlich,
ich will in der Regel eigentlich nur den Branche bearbeiten, in dem ich drinne bin, irgendwelche
anderen da Magic an und Weise zu ändern, zumal der Rebase die History meistens ziemlich
kaputt machen, weiß nicht ob das so sinnvoll ist, ach stimmt, das ist doch free to play,
tatsächlich muss ich es gar nicht kaufen, aber ich hab's noch nicht runtergeladen,
sag mal, warum ist die Musik so unterschiedlich laut, könnt ihr sich mal entscheiden, das
hier wieder, also dann machen, blub, so, DAKUXTV, 27mal, danke für den Sub, ich hab übrigens
schon wieder jemanden übersehen, also hier DAKU, danke für den Sub, Sven Supreme,
danke schön, 4 Monate, Hyper Subscription, wer ist der Fortnite spielen, ey ohne Scheiß,
wenn ich was spiele in nächster Zeit, was ich noch nicht gespielt hab, ich hab echt
vor mir Dota 2 mal anzugucken, ich weiß das ist übelst komplex und man zackt mega, aber
so für, dass man einfach was zum spielen hat, was auch nicht langweilig wird mal irgendwie
nach einem Monat, ist das glaub ich nicht schlecht, Credo, dankeschön, 8 Monate Subscription,
nee LOL mag ich nicht, ich kann dir nicht sagen warum LOL mag ich nicht, wenn dann
Dota 2, Siffende, dankeschön, 9 Monate Subscription, der Hype Train, ist das oder ist es jetzt
der Boost Train, gibt da mittlerweile mehrere Sachen, und was ist es jetzt, es ist der Boost
Train Leute, der Boost Train, der echte Thomas, dankeschön, jetzt fährt der Boost Train ab
und der Boost Train macht wahrscheinlich mal genau 0, nix, mal davon abgesehen, was soll
nämlich heute boosten, ich hab einen Stream an, wo der Chat eingeplant ist und wir schwätzen
ein bisschen, gucken uns vielleicht ein paar Videos an, und in eineinhalb Stunden spätestens
bin ich wieder off, also das heute zu boosten, aber dankeschön Leute für die ganzen Subs,
hab heute AWS Zeugs fürs Studium machen müssen, ist das so Paynes Champ, ich muss sagen,
mit AWS hab ich tatsächlich von den ganzen Cloud Services bisher am wenigsten gemacht,
ich hab Google Cloud verwendet, bisschen, nicht so viel, hauptsächlich für ihre Location
und Map API Geschichten, aber Google Cloud hat ein bisschen was mitgemacht, auf der Arbeit
ist relativ viel Azure, also quasi ausschließlich Azure, und bei mir privat ist es Hetzner oder
manchmal für bestimmte Sachen Digital Ocean, fertig, Gamepad, dankeschön für den Sub,
50%, gehts rund hier, übrigens heute ist mein Shelly angekommen, ich kann jetzt, ich weiß
gar nicht, ob ich euch das erzählt hab, wir haben doch letztens gebastelt hier im Stream,
was war jetzt mit dem Hetzner Code, das ist eine gute Frage, ich hab nix mehr gehört
bis jetzt, aber das ist nicht schlimm, ich hab vorhin die Rechnung fertig gemacht, spätestens
dann werd ich wieder was von hören, also wir haben noch vor ein paar Tagen hier diese
Geschichte gebaut für diese Hoftor Steuerung und ich hab mir jetzt einen Shelly bestellt,
einen Shelly 2, weil im Stream hatte ich ja selbst was gebaut und ich hab mir gedacht,
warum soll ich es selbst bauen, nimm einfach so ein fertiges Ding, jetzt hab ich mir eben
für 20 Euro oder so oder 25 Euro hier so ein Teil bestellt, passt besser und ich glaube
nicht, dass sich das lohnt, das wollte ich jetzt überhaupt nicht anklicken, glaub ich
nicht, dass sich das lohnt im Stream anzugucken, oh guck mal, der hat was geschrieben, der Typ,
was, plugin leads to the crash of Home Assistant, what, wie soll, wie soll ein Docker add on
Home Assistant crashen können, Leute ich hab mein plugin seit 3 Wochen am Start, da
crash nichts, what, it's crashing, was zum Teufel, was machen die, was soll das crashen,
ist das, ist, wie, das kann ich crashen, das kann den Hobbit, das ist ein Docker Container,
wie soll das den Host crashen, ich hab selbst auf dem Raspberry Pi 4 laufen, ich mein das
braucht halt ordentlich RAM, das braucht glaub ich 300 MB RAM oder sowas, ich hab selbst
auf dem Raspberry Pi 4 laufen, ja, what, what, vielleicht, vielleicht braucht's, also
ich kann mir nur vorstellen, dass die wirklich zu wenig RAM haben, was anderes hab ich keine
Ahnung, also ich wüsste wirklich nicht warum das crashen sollte, mal ganz davon abstehen,
das ist ein add on Docker Container, wie viel, ich guck jetzt mal wie viel RAM, wie viel,
ich guck jetzt mal wie viel RAM, ich mein dass das zu viel RAM braucht, ist möglich,
ich guck jetzt mal kurz, add on, add on store, add on dashboard, ich guck mal wie viel RAM
das grad braucht bei mir, ach RAM Auslastung kann man hier nicht sehen gescheit oder was,
wie kann man mit Docker gescheit sehen, out of the box, wie viel RAM ein Container frisst,
was geht das überhaupt irgendwie, ah muss ich mal gucken, da gibt's nicht viel zu updaten,
ok da geht der RAM aus, da geht 100% der RAM aus, was anderes kann ich mir nicht vorstellen,
locker stats, du kannst das add on nur über MQTT verwenden, was anderes geht gar nicht,
also ich hab echt keinen Plan, ich sag mal, viel RAM verbrauchen tut es jetzt im Endeffekt
auch nicht, das braucht ein paar Webrequests, eventuell muss man echt mal den RAM Verbrauch
checken, ich würd jetzt ja gerne nachgucken, aber ich kann im Stream glaub ich nicht auf
mein Home Assistant connecten, da ist zu viel, zu viel Leak angesagt, was hältst du von
Competitive Programming finde ich eigentlich eine coole Sache, ich guck mir teilweise
auch, ne Memorily könnte sein, aber ich hab nichts unmanaged drin, ich guck mal ich hab's
tagelang schon laufen, ich werd jetzt an den RAM Verbrauch dann sehen, ey da bin ich
zu pepega für, mein empfiehlt zu CCNA oder ähnliches, naja Linux und CCNA haben jetzt
erstmal nix miteinander zu tun, CCNA ist Cisco Netzwerkgedöns und Linux ist Linux,
ein haben im anderen nicht viel zu tun, CCNA weiß ich nicht ob ich das empfehle, ich hab
das auch gemacht, aber ehrlich gesagt nur weil ich es quasi kostenlos beim Provider
wo ich früher gearbeitet hab dabei gekriegt hab, ne hab ich den mitbekommen, wahrscheinlich
hat er sich über Oldschool Call of Duty Zeug ausgelassen, vermute ich mal, ihr schaut schon
weg versprochen, ok Sekunde noch, ich guck mal ob ich mich da überhaupt einloggen kann
drauf, guck mal ob ich mich überhaupt drauf einloggen kann, ich habe meinen CCNA im Abi
gemacht, muss es mir jetzt in der Ausbildung nochmal anhalten, ja ganz ehrlich ich hab
auch schon fast alles vergessen, weißt du was, das einzige was ich noch weiß, jetzt
ernsthaft das einzige was ich von Cisco Geräten noch weiß ist dass man EN am Anfang machen
muss, weiß noch irgendjemand mehr, denn ist nicht täglich verwendet, EN musst du am
Anfang machen, enable, mehr weiß ich nicht mehr, ok zeig mal kurz SSH, root, add, hab
ich überhaupt das Passwort für, ah ne Moment, yes, ok login geht, ich bin überrascht,
Leute ich muss euch mal kurz ausmachen, ich weiß nicht ob ich irgendwelche Docker Sachen
leake, Docker, was was, Docker, Stats, ach man kann Docker nicht benutzen davon, oh man,
ich muss es jetzt erstmal einschalten, dass es funktioniert, das würden wir jetzt mal
kurz machen, das interessiert mich nämlich wirklich, SSH, um was soll ich jetzt machen,
switch protected mode, gesicherter Modus soll ich ausschalten, ok, alles klar und jetzt
neu starten, ok, so jetzt muss ich euch tatsächlich nochmal kurz ausmachen, dann können wir gucken
ob was das addon braucht, also Docker, Stats, ne das braucht nicht viel, guckt, hier, das
noch 296 MB, also das ist jetzt nicht so, das ist jetzt nicht super viel, naja, sag
mal mal, wenn ey, wenn die, was hab ich gelegt, wenn die wirklich nen Pi haben mit einem G
oder 2G, dann ist wahrscheinlich zu wenig, ja, das könnte sein, das, wahrscheinlich
ist das so, ja, ich weiß nicht ob Home Assistant US überhaupt Swap an hat, sind wir eingeloggt
auf GitHub, nö, dann kann ich da jetzt auch nix posten, ok, dann sind wahrscheinlich
zu viel, Moin Cine, oder Cine, 42, guck mal, das Moskito addon hat auch, naja gut, das
addon verbraucht schon ein bisschen was, ich könnte das sicherlich ein ticken optimierter
machen, ja, ich hab ja im Endeffekt die ganze, einmalig die ganzen Responses im RAM, das
bisschen Jason da, ja wahrscheinlich brauchst du viel RAM, ja, das wird sein, wahrscheinlich
zu viel RAM Leute, restarte mal den Container, das ist ne gute Idee, schauen wir mal, docker
jetzt, ok, ich restarte mal, schauen wir mal, addons, Dashboard, neu starten, ok, ok, ok,
ok, guck mal, das spielt jetzt, ok, makeup.
Ich bin so
Monka w
Brauchen das so viel
Was macht es denn was zu
Okay, bis da der garbage collector läuft am land sind es wahrscheinlich 240. Nene es ist leute das ist kein. Memory leak
Als würde so ein memory leak aussehen das ist
Zeug was am anfang was macht es denn so viel
Was soll das denn bei was braucht es bitte schön so viel ram
Was macht es denn krass ist dass es ram verbraucht wie sauer
Ich meine es macht ein mqtt verbindung
Und ruft web requests ab warum brauchen das so viel
Bandung und ruft web requests ab warum brauchen das so viel ram
Ne dort also dort net runtime braucht auch nicht viel ich glaube ich glaube in
Hello world programm braucht was 50 mb ram oder so
Warum brauchen das so viel
Leute es wird zeit es in rust neu zu schreiben oder written in rust play singly fast
Aber warum das 6 622 mb
Was macht das denn krass ist
So viel brauchen da richtig fette sachen nicht
Okay ich will jetzt hier eigentlich nix großartig im stream hier debug aber was macht das denn krass ist für zeug
Das ist ja da verpasst der jede java software dagegen gerade
620 mb
Ja gut leute da hilft nix anderes wie
Ich mache gar nichts ich wundere mich warum warum ein programm so viel ram braucht das hat nix damit zu tun
Ne das container base image da läuft nix drinne großartig dass das
Guck mal man braucht die hälfte vom kompletten homo system
Null okay wenn der garbage collector läuft dann wird es weniger sein aber
Ich bin sehr verwirrt ich ich bin ich bin sehr verwirrt
Ich weiß nicht warum das so viel ram braucht
Das ist das ist die scharpe ja ich habe wirklich keine ahnung was was was braucht denn habe ich irgendwo
Mist mist eingebaut habe es vergessen rauszunehmen ich werde es ganz einfach machen ich werde einfach teile auskommandieren und gucken was passiert
Ja das nur das dort net program was da läuft
Ist es der mqtt client leute das kann sein
Das könnte wirklich der mqtt client sein weil am anfang sendet er doch alle möglichen
Sachen zurück wenn du dich neu connectest vielleicht hält er die irgendwie im ram bis man die bestätigt oder sowas
Ich ansonsten habe ich wirklich keinen plan was da an was da so viel ram brauchen sollte
Okay das wird das müsste ich mal näher analysieren aber nicht jetzt im stream
Jetzt also ich bin wirklich ich bin jetzt ich habe mir nie den ram verbrauch davon angeguckt weil ich eigentlich nicht damit gerechnet
Habt dass das so viel ram verbraucht für was was was ist das
Da war auch noch einmal im jahr das das treffen bei ahorn ente das ist ja schon uralt
Bei ahorn ente war ich nicht
Die rückenschmerzen den übung
Was warum den übung
Nee da ist nicht mehr am start
Gaming rücken
Warum ist da mein eigenes gameplay
Also ich habe keine ahnung warum es so viel ram verbraucht aber anscheinend liegt es daran dass es bei den abkackt dass es so viel ram verbraucht
Was mich ziemlich abfackt weil ich weiß null woher das kommt dass es so viel ram verbraucht
Mache ich hier irgendwelche dummen sachen
Wie kann man sowas debuggen
Na in dem fall ist das einfachste man könnte man könnte es im debug modus starten
Gucken was aber in dem fall ist wahrscheinlich wirklich das einfachste
Ich kommentiere mal ein paar sachen aus und gucke wo dann der riesen ram spike kommt
Ich meine braucht das hier jetzt auf einmal viel ram oder
Login
Braucht diese ganze web request geschichte viel ram vielleicht
Leute ich weiß woran es liegt
Ich weiß woran es liegt ich könnte wetten
Ich könnte wetten ich weiß woran es liegt das liegt an dem amazon aws shit
100 pro
Das liegt bestimmt an dem amazon kack
Line 1104 so viel zeilen hat das gar nicht
Das liegt das liegt bestimmt an dem amazon crap
Auch mal wetten ich kann es jetzt leider im stream nicht ausprobieren
Das liegt an dem amazon müll
Bestimmt also was anderes kann ich mir jetzt nicht kann ich mir jetzt nicht erklären
Weil ganz im ernst so paar web requests brauchen noch kein 600 mb ram
Aber dieses amazon zeug ich weiß ja nicht was der im hintergrund macht
Der initialisiert wahrscheinlich halb aws bei mir auf dem raspberry pi dann
Das ist es bestimmt
Weil im ernst was anderes ich wüsste wirklich nicht was das große ich machen sollte
Das liegt an aws
Kann ich mir vorstellen
Aber 600 mb ist halt wirklich heftig es geht jetzt ja langsam runter so als
Warum aws weil fiat aws verwendet um identifizierung und so zu machen
Und ich dachte mir bevor ich diese web requests zu aws von hand zusammen baue
Mache ich es halt mit der offiziellen aws library weil dann muss ich halt auf nichts
achten
Aber anscheinend ich könnte wetten das liegt an aws
Spiele Overwatch
Nee jetzt garantiert nicht und die nächsten tage muss ich mal gucken
Alter das verwirrt mich jetzt wirklich
Weil ansonsten keine ahnung was das sein aber das ist der amazon kram der machts wahrscheinlich
kaputt
Mache eine umfrage wer recht hat bekommt von dir ein hetsan code ja ich kann euch ein hetsan
code geben aber da geht aktuell nicht
Das stimmt
aws s3 net high memory usage
Ja
Das ist jetzt Amazon kram
Aber das liegt bestimmt das liegt bestimmt an Amazon aws zeug
Was hast du die hast du ein Shellyplug gekauft
Habt ihr das eigentlich mitbekommen dieser typ der im schach beschissen hat und der angeblich
irgendeinen buttplug im pobus hatte der ihm irgendwie ach was ich habs nur so grob überflogen
der
Ok ihr denkt euch das so ok ok chess ok moment moment moment
Ich muss jetzt gucken nach was ich suche
Ich muss jetzt gucken nach fuck nach was suche ich denn moment ich muss auf den zweiten browser
suchen
Ok ich glaube das das kann ich
Ok alle ablehnen also chess gunner evolving buttplugs ai ok also
Ja ja also also ich weiß ja nicht aws s3 aber da steht überhaupt keine news dazu
Na also ergeblich
Er ergeblich hat er so ein ding im bobbers gehabt was ihm dann durch die vibration anzeigt
was er für ihre seine schachfiguren ziehen soll aber wie gesagt bestätigt ist er da
nix bei
Chess player accused of cheating via buttplug
Ja mal gucken was da rauskommt mal gucken was da rauskommt oh mann
Das ist zwar eine kreative art zu cheaten oder
sich in buttplug in pobus schieben und dann anhand der vibrationen encoden was man jetzt
machen muss das demnächst beim nächsten beim nächsten turnier musste dann musste dann
wirklich pobus kontrolle machen
Sag mal gibt es irgendein neues meme was ich nicht verstehe
Was hat es mit 1104 auf sich ist das ist das das deutsche ist das das deutsche 420 oder
was jetzt
Ja das frage ich mich auch
Man weiß ja noch gar nicht ob das ob das wirklich raus ob das wirklich stimmt ja
Soll ich lieber programmer mit snap oder mit abt runterladen mit abt snap ist crap
flatpack flatpack ist tatsächlich ganz ok
Was ist besser als abt nix der package manager deine distribution ist eigentlich immer am
besten
Wo bin ich geladen ja du bist gerade zum unglücklich zeitpunkt gekommen
Oh keine ahnung ist eine gute frage
Hatte die arbeit bei einem isp spaß gemacht ja aber der laden war kacke also an sich das
was man da gemacht hat fand ich sehr nice gerade auch dass man da noch täglich im rechenzentrum
gewesen ist das hat mich zumindest zur damaligen zeit fand ich das richtig nice
Ich konnte euch sagen wenn ich bin im dunklen immer durchs rechenzentrum gelaufen weil man
im dunklen besser statuslämpchen und sowas sieht ich habe immer das ich habe immer das
licht ausgelassen bin ich bin ich durch dunkle rechenzentrum gegangen da konnte ich euch
anhand der lichter sagen ob alles in ordnung ist oder beziehungsweise wo was nicht in ordnung
ist ich bin morgens immer so um halb acht bin ich durch dunkle bin ich eine halbe stunde
durch dunkle rechenzentrum gelaufen und hat mir die lichtchen angeguckt und ich wusste
immer sofort wenn irgendwo ein lichtchen brennt was nicht brennen musste und also irgendwelche
wadenlämpchen oder sowas und das war jetzt nicht das größte rechenzentrum es war aber
auch nicht das kleinste und wie gesagt ich konnte euch das sagen aber ich bin eine halbe
stunde angeguckt und ich wusste gleich wie das normal aussieht wenn es blinkt und wie
es nicht normal aussieht
wer braucht monitor in genaue turnschuhe admin auf gehts du hast das gefühl dass dein software
rate mega langsam ist wie du das verifizieren kannst ganz einfach du machst dd und kopierst
was und guckst wie schnell das ist oder aber wenn du es genauer wissen willst nimmst du
dir irgendeinen ssd oder festplatten benchmark der dann auch zugriffszeiten und kleine dateien
und sowas testet aber wenn es schon sequenziell langsam ist dann ähm tja du machst dd ich
würde erstmal ein dd machen das ist das aller einfachste dd aus dev0 nach keine ahnung
blub punkt bin na hd palm ist nicht so sinnvoll in dem fall das schreibt ja auch nicht viel
das testet ein bisschen was und die ersten 5mb landen dann im cache und es sieht super
schnell aus ich würde ein dd machen mal von irgendwie 500 gig oder so und machst du von
df0 nach blub punkt bin auf dann rate drauf dann sagst du status gleich was ist es status
progres oder sowas dass dd auch die übertragungsraten anzeigt alternativ piepst du das ganze nach
pv dann siehst du genau was er macht dann guckst du mal also die schönere anzeige ist natürlich
ich zeig das mal kurz also die schönere anzeige ich geh mal kurz hier raus die schönere anzeige
durch df gleich du musst aber du musst ein bisschen mehr df0 so dann kannst du es theoretisch
piepen nach pv das sieht dann ein bisschen sieht dann ein bisschen schöner aus und dann
wieder nach dd und sagst dann o f blub punkt bin und jetzt ist wichtig bs gleich keine
ahnung ein m oder oder 4m oder sowas block block size sondern sagste count count und
dann halt wie oft du diese vier megabyte schreiben willst da ist kein boot drive weg ja sagst
dir irgendwie keine ahnung vier gigabyte schreiben man siehst du wie schnell das ist man siehst
er bei mir auf die ssd hält sich die geschwindigkeit in grenzen warum ist das so langsam muss
irgendwelches vm erzeugt sein ich habe das auch gar nicht auf der ssd li moment habe ich das nicht
liegt auf der ssd ich bin in der vm ja und eigentlich kein ding denn es stellt kann nicht
gelöscht werden und nein mal ohne pipe also sollte es wenig einfluss haben status nehmen
es ist status es ist status gleich progress no pass das hat wirklich nur 60 mb die sekunde
oder sonst was naja gut warum auch immer das muss ich jetzt nicht verstehen warum das so
lahm ist auf die ssd aber gut soll jetzt nicht mein problem sein ja habe ich immer noch
immer noch also sobald sich was gutes ergibt was remote arbeit ermöglicht muss nicht zu
100 prozent sein aber sagen wir so ein tag die woche ist ok oder kommt also ein tag die
woche als vier tage woche ein tag die woche ins büro ist ok beziehungsweise 100 prozent
remote ist natürlich das bei mir bevorzugte weil dann kann ich schlicht und ergreif noch
irgendwo arbeiten die sonst wo sind wenn die stelle 100 prozent remote ist es mir auch
egal ob die in tschechien oder in england oder in hamburg sind was juckt es mich ja
ja habe ich immer noch also sobald sich da was gutes ergibt was remote ist und was ordentlich
bezahlt und vor allem was mir auch irgendwie von der arbeit her zu sagt bin ich weg also
wenn du was hast sagt bescheid ja heute heute ist sehe ich da nichts mehr bei habe ich euch
mal erzählt dass ich eigentlich 150 prozent sehkraft habe so was geht ja genau eisflieg
dankeschön für den sub hast die festplatte halt net pass und ich meine mehr als als 60
mb die sekunde sollte das ja aber auch mit dem normalen vm krempel schaffen aber naja
was willst du machen hält sich hält sich in grenzen hast du bei der twitter man kann
die schrift hat ja habe ich hast du denn geschrieben na ehrlich wer bist du denn und was machst
du so für wuppler für content ich bin wuppler und ich lese den chat zusammen mit allen anderen
ne normalerweise das siehst du wahrscheinlich auch in der video history machen wir eigentlich
eher technik content ab und zu mal spielen wir auch irgendwas aber heute bin ich angekommen
einfach zum schwätzen ohne großartig was zu machen vielleicht gucken wir doch ein paar
videos an aber ansonsten gibt es heute nichts spannendes ja das ist sehr langsam wundert
mich jetzt auch kann man da noch etwas einstellen moment current size 5,6 naja muss ja so sein
advanced man weiß es nicht schon streamthema gefunden ne juckt mich auch nicht ganz ehrlich
ist es schnell genug brauchst du beim mikrotik winbox oder webfig beides ich benutze beides
webfig ist der beste name für den web interface aller zeiten webfig das ist echt der beste
name kann auf deutsch ausgesprochen also ich benutze webfig wenn ich mal kurz was nachgucken
will und winbox wenn ich beispielsweise firewall regeln einstellen will also wenn es ein bisschen
was ordentliches sein muss auch in der richtigen reinfolge und ich sicher sein muss dass es
auch alles richtig angezeigt wird dann winbox und wenn ich mal kurz leses dhcp technisch
nachgucken will web interface das siehe iber mikrotik habe ich tatsächlich so gut wie
nicht verwendet das was ich bisher davon gesehen habe hat mich auch nicht geschockt kennst
du was magic warm hole das hört sich das hört sich ein bisschen unanständig an fast schon
für feiltransfer ne sagt mir nix teilst du deine us für für spiele und platten ja aber
nicht zwischen us und platte ich habe eine ssd für system und ich habe eine zweite ssd
für anderen krempel wie vms und sowas zum beispiel noch eine magnet festplatte stimmt
gar nicht ich habe eine ssd für system eine ssd noch und auch noch zwei weitere drei ssd
und eine magnet festplatte dran also eigentlich nicht danach geteilt aber ich habe beispielsweise
download auf der magnet platte und sowas das bringt ja nichts damit sich seine ssd vollzumüllen
ich wollte kann auch was anderes probieren was macht denn die alte was macht denn die
alte stream vm was macht denn die alte stream vm vielleicht ist es dort schneller mit der
platte wo liegt moment wo liegt die ne was war es ist habe ja immer so bescheuern abgetestet
wo liegt denn die platte da c doppelpunkt ok vielleicht ist ja schneller kommen wir
mal dd if gleich def 0 block size 4 mb ist eigentlich schon ganz gut uf gleich plupp
punkt bin status progress wirklich viel schneller ist es auch nicht oder
es war jetzt ziemlich pepega also da muss ich auch die plox muss ich muss die plox
muss ich die plox heißt doppelt einstellen ich glaube schon aber trotzdem so viel schneller
ist es jetzt auch nicht es ist aber schneller es ist schneller aber es ist nicht wirklich
so schnell wie ich das gerne hätte aber aber es ist schneller dass soviel soviel ist schon
mal ist schon mal klar aber sie jetzt nicht da um irgendwelche vms zu debuggen da habe
ich kein bock drauf muss ich wahrscheinlich morgen schon wieder machen bei den vms die
bank nicht aber irgendwas in der richtung bestimmt frage in den chat haben wir eine
stärkere cpu bestellt wenn ich die einfach tausche könnte ich mit mir noch 11 mit mir
noch zehn probleme bekommen eigentlich ist es ja mainboard wechsel aber ich weiß nicht
ob microsoft es überhaupt erzählt hat bisher nach welchen kriterien sie entscheiden wann
sich ein rechner geändert hat ja könnte sein aber du kannst deine windows lizenz sicherlich
dann über den offiziellen weg umziehen das geht bestimmt habe ich aber noch nie gemacht
oder aber ich wollte es gerade sagen oder du holst den oem key vom china kines und weiter
geht es vielleicht liegt ja ich habe ich weiß es nicht woran es liegt es ist aber schnell
genug es ist so schnell dass ich keine ja pro probleme habe damit ich werde da nichts
machen hast du schon mal was mit telefonanlagen gemacht zum glück zum glück nicht zum glück
nein nein habe ich nicht bin ich auch sehr froh drüber dass ich da nichts mit machen
musste bisher weil das ist wirklich immer extrem painz champ
ich habe kein bit locker
aber ich kann es gibt pro und kontra für beides also man kann ohne probleme auch wohl
also nicht bitte worden sondern wollt war der wollt worden auch verwenden ja gerade wenn
man beispielsweise eher das ganze mit einem browser verwenden will und eventuell von mehreren
geräten kein bock hat sich irgendwie key pass datei zu sünden ist es alles legitim also
ich finde kann man beides verwenden ist beides sinnvoll ich persönlich verwende key pass
hauptsächlich aus dem grund weil ich key pass die letzten 15 jahre oder so verwende
unter alles drinne steht und das ist auch so ziemlich die einzige datei ist die ich tatsächlich
regelmäßig sünke und back ab weil wenn die verloren geht wäre wirklich doof
so gibt es irgendwas spannendes was man sich angucken kann was haben wir denn hier nintendo
das ist die sache von microsoft und sony früher aber auch gewesen was sie da geschrieben
haben teilweise für den putz sind da stand mal bei sony stand man auf der seite man soll
seine playstation direkt an den router anschließen und in eine dmz packen das ist auf so vielen
ebenen bescheuert dass mir da gar nichts mehr zu einfällt fängt ja schon an mit dass die
bezeichnung dmz vollkommen pepega ist in dem fall hat nichts mit einer dmz zu tun was sie
da beschrieben haben wie funktioniert die cloud von bitworn nee die ist nicht kostenlos
und bitworn in der cloud würde ich auch nicht verwenden wenn schon würde ich ein self hosted
bitworn beziehungsweise volt worden nehmen und das dann im intern benutzen als web interface
aber ich würde im leben nicht das letzte was ich machen würde ist einen cloud service
zu verwenden für passwörter das ist meiner ansicht nach das dümmste was man machen kann
du vertraust einem cloud anbieter wo du überhaupt nicht nachvollziehen kannst was der macht
was der in seiner software du vertraust dem deine wichtigsten passwörter accounts an im
leben nicht man sollte niemals passwörter bei einem cloud dienstleister hausen und selbst
wenn die sagen ja wir verschlüsseln noch alles kleinzeitig das kann das irgendjemand
von euch nachvollziehen ob das so ist die können viel erzählen wenn der tag lang ist
ja und im schlimmsten fall wird ihr update surfer übernommen und das ding pusht updates
und installiert das update und dann pusht das irgendwie eure accounts zu den zu den
russen oder den china chinesen oder so also im leben nicht ich würde nie passwörter in
die cloud packen nie egal wie sehr in diesem anbieter vertrauen
nee aber es gibt eine open source nachbau wobei doch ich glaube der bid one server ist
tatsächlich open source aber der muss wohl sehr ressourcenintensiv sein ob er jetzt so
ressourcenintensiv ist wie mein home assistant addon das weiß ich natürlich nicht aber
er soll relativ ressourcenintensiv sein deswegen von benutzen die meisten leute das da ist das
ganze finanziert wahrscheinlich mit premium abos oder so da würde ich das hier nehmen
das hier finanziert sich gar nicht das ist einfach weil der typ nett ist und es programmiert
hat für leute kostenlos zum benutzen das kannst du machen aber ganz im ernst ich würde
meinen password manager nicht ins internet freigeben selbst mit reverse proxy und mal
mindestens basic aus besser irgendeinen authentifizierungs provider noch und zwei
faktor authentifizierung machen aber ganz im ernst ich würde meinen nur das wirklich die
allerletzte das allerletzte wie soll ich sagen so schritt wenn es gar nicht anders geht dass
ich meinen password manager ins internet freigeben würde hast du mal andere suchmaschinen außer
google verwendet ja ich verwende tatsächlich relativ oft da go habe ich teilweise sogar
deutlich sinnvolle ergebnisse wie bei google google findet zwar potenziell mehr aber google
findet oftmals viel shit also keine ahnung nehmen wir mal nehmen wir mal das beispiel ich
würde jetzt nach meinem neuen github projekt suchen da findet geht da findet da da go zwei
seiten mit halbwegs sinnvollen matches google findet acht seiten mit teilweise übelsten
schwachsinn die damit überhaupt nichts zu tun haben also da da go verwende ich recht oft
bitworn läuft bei mir als dockercontainer wunderbar
würdest du vpn für bitworn verwenden also wenn ich wirklich als das erste ich würde mir erst
mal überlegen brauche ich denn wirklich alle meine passwörter auf meinem mobilen gerät weil
in deinem password manager hast du keine ahnung 500 passwörter drin stehen das sind sachen drin
vom online banking bis zum onlyfans account und wahrscheinlich brauchst du den onlyfans account
nicht mobile oder du brauchst beispielsweise dein banking login nicht mobile oder du brauchst
dein account für ebay nicht mobile oder was auch immer also normalerweise braucht man mobile 2 3
accounts ja das ist der email account oder die zwei email accounts vielleicht ja dann
auch für irgendwelche web services wo man die app nicht verwendet sondern über den browser benutzt
ansonsten ist doch im endeffekt mobile selten dass man da passwörter braucht normalerweise
normalerweise brauchst du zwei bis drei passwörter mobile vielleicht das war es so das heißt wenn
das der fall ist muss man sich immer überlegen ist es überhaupt sinnvoll dass man alle passwörter
irgendwie mobile verfügbar machen will so wenn man jetzt doch sagt ja ich will das ich will alle
meine passwörter auch von mobil drauf zugreifen dann bleibt dir nichts anderes übrig sicherheitstechnisch
als in vpn zu verwenden da du kannst in reverse proxy machen du kannst basic orts zwei fakte
autentifizierung was immer davor machen ich persönlich bin aber in vpn ist immer noch das beste was du machen kannst weil
dann gibst du ja nicht wirklich deinen oder am besten noch mit klein zertifikat plus zwei
fakte autentifizierung macht so viel wie geht nee aber vpn ist insofern das beste weil du gibst ja
nicht dann dein password manager frei sondern du kommst dann erstmal per vpn in den extra netz von
wo du dann wieder freischaltung hast auf ein paar interne dienste das heißt du musst erstmal dein
vpn deine vpn autentifizierung machen plus alles was dran hängt vielleicht noch irgendwie den token
dir zuschicken lassen oder so danach musst du dich dann noch zum service verbinden und dort dann
noch mal ein master password und sonst was eingeben also das ist ok vpn ist in ordnung vpn in dem fall
ist meiner meinung nach auch das beste ich meine noch besser ist natürlich du musst es gar nicht
freigeben nach außen hin ja habe ich auch
mv ja genau mv
du musst mal also muss man es gibt unter linux keine dateiendung in dem fall du kannst auch
mehrere punkte in die datei machen und so was du kannst auch punkt txt komplett weglassen aber wenn
du halt eine datei mit einem punkt txt drinne hast machst du mv dann ist im mau im mv ist
im endeffekt move ja du benennst das um von test txt nach test meinung zu war ja gar ziemlich
gute geschichte war ja gar ist poc also ich habe die meisten sagen bei mir daheim mit open vpn
gemacht wenn ich vpn verwendet habe als ich noch oft vpn verwendet habe mittlerweile habe ich ja
von außen nach innen gar nichts mehr ich habe kein vpn wenn ich jetzt vpn machen würde sagen
wir zum beispiel ich möchte in vpn machen weil ich demnächst meinen hof tor von von unterwegs auf
und zu machen will oder ziemlich bescheuertes anwendungsgebiet ich gebe es zu aber nur mal
theoretisch dann würde ich wahrscheinlich wirecard verwenden hatte julian bemlich
fünffaktor authentifizierung wurde trotzdem gehackt war da nicht was wie das finanziert
wird wahrscheinlich durch werbung weiß ich nicht ob die werbung machen oder durch premium benutzer
oder irgendwelche premium plants oder oder sonst was die werden schon ganz gut verdient
wahrscheinlich ist das sogar absicht dass die leute diesen service verwenden und dann sich so
auf den service verlassen dass sie denken jetzt hätte ich gerne ein bisschen mehr und also
wahrscheinlich ist das sogar dazu um die leute ins premium irgendwie zu zu bringen waren ja viele
services kostenlose base aber es ist ja auch das beste was du machen kannst weil wenn die leute
bei dir ist beim ökosystem drin sind dann kriegst du sie leichter dazu irgendwelche paid services
zu verwenden so also was was macht nintendo denn jetzt wollen wir so angucken least for example
here's a page where they talk about how to set up port forwarding you know what that means don't
worry i'll explain a minute but let's take a look it says assign a network ip to your console okay
and it has a link to another page we'll see later okay wie geht's weiter lorin to your router settings
also da würde ich mir schon mal gedanken machen wenn ich um eine konsole ins internet zu bringen
mich überhaupt auf meine router anmelden müsste höchstens für dhcp reservierung aber selbst das
ist blödsinnig weil warum sollte eine konsole eine feste ip benötigen
also eine feste insofern dass die sich gar nicht ändert dhcp ip ist ja auch fest bis die lease
abläuft für was ist so leute wisst ihr wie lang ist so die standard dhcp lease ist vier tage oder
sowas locate the port fording settings all seems all right but then it gets to the part where it
tells you which ports to forward which are all of them eins eins bis 65.000 535 udp nintendo was ist
denn mit euch los das ergibt ja überhaupt keinen sinn warum sollte man das denn machen also das
ergibt vielleicht aus nintendosicht sinn so nach dem motto wir sind nicht in der lage löcher in
natt zu machen oder wollen p2p hosting und wir sind zu dumm ist ordentlich zu programmieren aber
das ist doch total unsinnig war ganz davon abgesehen sollte die switch oder die wie oder was dahinten
dran hängt weil wirklich in irgendeiner art und weise angreifbar sein dann hast du halt auch
schöne gleich zugriff drauf also das ist das ist ja hängen geblieben you'll oft need to
ford nein man sollte das nie nie niden now many of you already immediately right ja das
wird es jetzt nicht erinnert und potentially dangerous this is but for those of you okay
mit den anfangen wir mal gucken was er sagt also wir gucken uns jetzt kein port fording video an
when you're using a computer or other device there are potentially many programs running on it
simultaneously ja all need to share the same internet connection so to solve this there are
a bunch of what are called ports which you can sort of think of like lanes on a highway each
application running will claim its chat preisfrage und wie nennt man die kombination von einer
ip adresse plus port also wie nennt man das worauf dann beispielsweise der htp lauscht
oder worauf dann steam lauscht die kombination aus ip und port socket easy endpunkt ist auch
okay endpunkt lasse mir auch gefallen wenigstens wenigstens six head chat heute wieder angesagt
exit ich bin zufrieden mit euch bin hut ab ich habe kein fedora hut tipp emote aber high
IQ chat so mag ich das own port and send out connections on it in so-called packets of data
and they also listen on that port for any responses now each packet contains info like which computer
it came from and which port it's using and the responses will also have that info so the router
knows where to send those responses to which device and just like your home has a public
and the responses will also responses now each packet will claim its own port and send out
connections on it in so-called packets of data and they also listen on that port for any responses
now each packet contains info like which computer it came from which port it's using and the
responses will also have that info so the router knows where to send those responses to which
device and just like your home has a public ip address all devices that are connected to your
router have a local is how the router can direct where to send various data but what do you do if
you have some data packets that come in and aren't a response to anything they're just
done with it that was support firewall by default your router will just block such data for starters
because it wouldn't even know which device in your network to send information to that is good
that he says that is what many people always get wrong we really have to make a stream where
i try to avoid all the anglicisms that is what many people don't really understand
so that's not the firewall where there is a drop rule in it the router simply doesn't know where
he should send it he has a public ip and you have no idea 50 devices where should he send it
when a package arrives he doesn't even know where he should know it's not an answer to a
package where something went out before he simply doesn't know that comes to his
externe ip adresse gerichtet also an ihn auf innen port und er sagt gibt es nicht bei mir
gibt es nix auf port 4 4 4 4 und deswegen schmeißt das weg oder schickt innen rejected oder sonst
was genau das ist das ist das warum es nicht funktioniert also sprich wenn du natt machst
mit einer public ip und du nicht port weiter leitung einrichtest weiß der router schlicht
und ergreifend nicht wo er sachen hinschicken sollt das liegt nicht daran dass da irgendwie
eine firewall drauf ist die das drop das würde komplett ohne irgendwie paketfilter
geschichten gehen er wüsste schlicht und ergreifend nicht was er damit machen soll
und auch wenn er es hat würde man ein ganze bunt von bots von überall über die internet
das stimmt wohl die china chinesen und die sind auch am start da ja zum beispiel splatoon
wo ich bis heute nicht verstehe warum schafft es nintendo nicht ordentlich mal
ein paar server hinzustellen es ist ja nicht so als würden splatoon server jetzt irgendwie
unsummen an ressourcen fressen kann der heutigen zeit wo cloud ressourcen billig sind und sich
gerade game server auch wunderbar skalieren lassen ich verstehe das problem nicht gut
nintendo denkt sich warum bisschen was ausgehen wenn man es auch komplett umsonst haben kann aber
das ist komplett komplett für den arsch also das spielen keine 15 millionen leute gleichzeitig
selbst dann sieht man doch dass es bei anderen games funktioniert da machen sie auch kohle mit
wenn das 15 millionen leute gleichzeitig spielen würden also dass das nicht also das p2p hosting
immer noch so ein ding ist aber es ist einfach so nintendo und online sachen waren leider schon
immer verkackt und als sie diesen twitch premium service angekündigt haben dachte ich mir aber
auch schon von anfang an was genau also warum genau sollte man sich das kaufen für ns klassiker
ns klassiker kann ich auf dem emulator spielen besser als von nintendo selbst also das habe
ich nicht verstanden und ansonsten ja die splatoon app ist auch total verkackt also nintendo und
online ist so ein so ein echt so ein spezial ding was verstehe nicht be the host and act like a
temporary server where the other players connect to that console and that console runs the server
and that game will use a certain port like 55000 555 or multiple might be a range of them that is
where port forwarding comes in it's basically like telling your router hey if you get any
unsolicited data trying to access port 55555 let that through and send it directly to the
console at whatever ip address and while there are some minor risks to this that i won't go into
like for example if another application uses the same port while the game isn't running generally
a couple game ports is not that big a deal but now you're probably you see the problem
with nintendo's advice it's effectively telling you to allow all connections that are unsolicited
through your router and go directly to your switch or whatever nintendo console apparently they don't
have a standard set of ports that different games use so instead of maybe telling you which ports
to forward for which specific game you're worried about they just tell you to forward literally
every single port does it mean that your network is immediately going to be hacked no not necessarily
especially if you must say or dp port sind jetzt meistens auch nicht so das ding wo die
die üblichen verdächtigen dran lauschen aber trotzdem ganz ehrlich mal einfach alle dp ports
aufmachen und sei es nur auf eine nintendo switch trotzdem keine gute idee
was mein chat das muss ich mal kurz lesen das habe ich gerade so im ersten blick nicht verstanden
was was auch ein thema sein könnte dass die hardware beziehungsweise server denn da so extrem die
bestellen noch keine extra server um da ihr splatoon ihre splatoon server wenn ich server
meine meine ich keine hardware das muss ich auch mal dazu sagen ich mein irgendwas was so aussieht
wie ein server wenn man sich darauf einloggt und worauf man den splatoon server dann laufen
lassen oder ein splatoon service drauf laufen lassen könnte ich meine damit nicht die hardware
das die müssen auch ihre services nicht mehr aufstecken nintendo lässt doch so was heute nicht
mehr selber laufen die gehen zu aws oder die gehen zu google oder die gehen zu irgendem vielleicht
gehen die auch zu vielleicht haben die auch selbst so was ja kann ja sein nintendo hat ja genug kohle
vielleicht haben wir auch selbst ein paar rz in der welt rumstehen das glaube ich aber nicht und
selbst wenn dort die splatoon aber dabei laufen lassen ist kein ding du brauchst ja keine extra
hardware dafür wahrscheinlich läuft so was heutzutage noch nicht mal in der vm würde ich
jetzt mal tippen also ich bin jetzt kein spiele programmierer ich kann mir das nur eben so wenn
ich mir überlege wie ich einen online service aufbauen würde also sagen wir mal ich würde
ein mmo betreiben oder halt nicht sagen wir mal ich möchte splatoon server betreiben dann würde
ich gucken dass ich dieser service ein bisschen ausplitten lässt also zum beispiel dass man die
systeme die so was wie log in machen log in systeme ich weiß auf erwacht zeigt gerade was
anderes aber das sind wahrscheinlich nicht die die super viel last pro user brauchen die aber
viele user abkriegen so das ist was das lässt sich wunderbar wie man so schön sagt horizontal
skalieren also das letzte irgendwelche load balancer hin oder denkst du in irgendeiner
art und weise was der last verteilung aus vielleicht machst du auch dns load balancing
wäre in dem fall tatsächlich gar nicht so doof dann hast lässt du nämlich einfach den client
entscheiden ob er jetzt zu log in server abc oder d geht in dem fall wäre wäre das stimmt nicht
wirklich den client entscheiden aber ich nenne es jetzt einfach mal so dann kannst du nämlich das
gut gut aufplitzen machst du mehrere eingänge vielleicht sogar mit load balancer dahinter
skalierst du schön horizontal dein log in service dass du keine queue von 50.000 leuten hast was
immer ein bisschen problematisch ist wenn irgendwelche datenbank abfragen gemacht werden
müssen und er wenn datenbank reiz gemacht werden müssen also spricht zum beispiel der user will
sich einloggen natürlich da muss man in der datenbank geguckt werden datenbank reads kriegst du
relativ gut parallelisiert datenbank reiz ist die frage was du da unten drunter verwendest also
klassische klassische datenbank cluster ist eher so dass einer so der masterknoten ist über den
geschrieben wird und der rest ist meistens read was aber auch nicht schlimm ist weil es zu 90
prozent reads sind aber wenn halt ganz viele logins kommen und dann willst du pro login was
auch immer die logins speichern oder irgendwie so was ja da gibt es ein paar gibt es ein paar
rights ich bin ich der große datenbank cluster ich kann es da im detail nicht erklären ich
weiß nur dass du es beispielsweise bei postgres dass es da relativ dass es da relativ beliebt
ist du hast einen cluster von denen kannst du alle notes fragen aber du kannst nur über eine note
schreiben was für web services wunderbar ist weil 90 prozent sind reads das ist das erste was ich
machen würde und das zweite ist dass meine game server eben auch entsprechend skalierbar sind was
von der idee hier eigentlich eine super super einfache geschichte sein soll weil so ein game
server muss halt pro lobby einmal gestartet werden und das würde sich wunderbar eignen halt als
einzelner service dann halt gestartet dort du hast den login server und den matchmaking server in
einem da wird dann die lobby erstellt matchmaking gemacht so und dann wird gesagt keine ahnung diese
acht spieler spielen gegen diese acht spieler und dann wird ein service dann wird ein service
gestartet wie auch immer gearteter form ja wahrscheinlich irgendwas kontinuerisiert das
oder du hast schon welche laufen oder ein server kann mehrere sessions wie auch immer das programmiert
es und dann schickst du über deinen matchmaking server den clients einfach diesen server da sagst
du hier das ist euer server matchmaking da kriegt in die unique id und connecten sich die leute
da drauf und dann sind sie auf ihrem server und können spielen und nachdem eine session quasi
so eine lobby gleich eine server instanz eine eine game server instanz ist lässt sich das super
parallelisieren du busst vielleicht ein esx cluster oder dein kubernetes cluster oder was
auch immer du hast bisschen aufstocken aber das ist wahrscheinlich bei sowas wie amazon und google
auch für ein fettes geld nicht notwendig die haben genug also ganz ehrlich das ist einfach nur
weil die zu faul sind bei nintendo oder aber weil die sich denken warum geld ausgeben wenn man es
auch kostenlos machen kann ich das tatsächlich ich sage ich erkläre dir auch ich erkläre dir
auch was zu gibt wenn du mir datenbank clustern erklärst ja ich weiß ich wollte auch was im
streamer wollten wir was machen bester dns server für eigene domains im lokalen netz
nimm den dns aber von deinem router und machs nicht unnötig kompliziert ich verwende auch
den dns auf einer mikrotik kiste gut ich habe fürs mobile für fürs wlan habe ich noch ein
blok nee wie heißt das ding etgard etgard home genau habe ich dort installiert als dns blokka
für mobile geräte aber sonst ich verwende dns server von meinem router warum nicht unter der
haube ist es bei ganz vielen in dns mask auf vielen liluks basierten system also bei bei
mikrotik bin ich mir relativ sicher dass es in dns mask ist bei der fritz box vermute ich
mal unter der haube auch in dns mask weiß ich aber nicht dns macht es recht beliebt ja das stimmt
ja das gibt einen grund aber ich kann es dir nicht mehr genau sagen wir haben mal so ein
vergleich stream gemacht ich war der meinung dass etgard home sich besser eignet für das was ich
machen wollte ich wollte irgendwelche spezial filter regeln oder sowas machen ich weiß es
nicht mehr aber das hat ging damit besser also bein ist auf jeden fall overkill dafür dns
mass ist dafür super dns mass kann so gut wie alles bein ist ja auch eher so dinger ist ja
eher so was wie wenn man auto updates dann machen will und wenn man halt wirklich viele viele domains
hat die andere auflösen wollen bei einem also sprich wenn ich provider bin oder sowas und ich
mal ich halt sage hier ich habe zwei dns server die sind zuständig für für diese domains dann
aber ansonsten ganz ehrlich die beiden config ist auch abfuck aha da muss ich ehrlich sagen
habe ich wenig plan von ok guck mal weiter was erzählt er noch dazu
können sie sich entscheiden ich persönlich bin ja für router aber viele amis und gerade
sysco fans sind für router deswegen sage ich ja udp ist meistens nicht so schlimm in der regel
kann man davon ausgehen dass das ganze zeug das web interface von der ip cam oder so dass das auf
tcp läuft allerdings der live stream auf der ip cam der kann durchaus udp sein ich glaube
rtsp ist glaube ich standardmäßig sogar udp wobei viele es trotzdem über tcp verwenden
weil pakete verloren und so zeug sie sind massive security risk many devices like the ones i
mentioned da hat er recht smart devices may have a web wieso sollte man live stream auch
tcp machen nur ja weil du vielleicht sicherstellen willst dass nichts verloren geht man könnte jetzt
sagen live stream mit low latency auf keinen fall weil was juckt mich im paket was ich
bekomme weil es verloren gegangen ist eine halbe sekunde später ja also wenn das super
low latency sein soll dann ja aber ansonsten hast ja eher mal einen buffer von so eins zwei
sekunden und dann ist das schon sinnvoll warum nicht ich meine wenn du ein zwei sekunden buffer
hast und mal was verloren geht und es wird wieder geschickt das ist ja dann rechtzeitig da oder kann
man das schon machen also ich muss sagen ich habe auch viel bessere erfahrungen gemacht bei meinen
kameras mit rtsp über tcp mag sein dass der rtsp server auf den kameras einfach kacke ist aber mit
tcp verbund funktioniert es tatsächlich deutlich besser
so you control it like through a web browser but a lot of times these will have a default
publicly known login like a default password and if someone tries probing your ip address
they'll see web interface for this rand device password manager benutzen können machen ja klar
warum nicht mache ich welchen welchen password manager verwendet ihr fragezeichen was haben
wir denn was soll ich in der reinschreiben chat sagt man was soll ich noch zur auswahl
also key pass mit worden klaut mit worden und self hosted
last pass kackel oder nix papier
mehr kann man nicht mehr kann man nicht hinzufügen bei der umfrage gehen es gehen nur fünf
dann machen wir das so da lasse ich passt last pass weg machen wir andere hin so und dann
ok umfrage beginn schauen wir mal bin ich mal gespannt was was da rauskommt
also key pass ich bin auch an ich klicke mal hier ich bin ich bin auch an key pass user
die default
ich das fall synchronisieren auf mobile geräte und so gar nicht ich mache da ab und zu einen
backup von und fertig andere ok es verwenden relativ viel leute andere sachen gut da ist
dann wahrscheinlich ja habe ich mal kurz getestet aber nie weiter verwendet n pass den trau ich
mich weil da klein nicht open source ist wer weiß was die da machen ok key pass gefolgt
von ja andere wer zählt gefolgt von bitte waren klaut ok tatsächlich aber bitte waren
interessant ein paar sind all school machen es auf papier also in der config von key pass steht
alles im klartext was das wäre mir jetzt neu das würde ja den kompletten sinn eines password
managers mit master password die fieten was ein satz alda wieder das würde den sinn eines
password managers die fieten mal ganz davon abgesehen selbst wenn er jetzt was ok ok mal
mal ausprobieren key pass ich glaube das ist eine ziemlich glaube das sind ziemlich alte
key pass version die ich hier gerade habe check update egal selbst da new new so desktop desktop
database master password 123456 123456 estimated quality beste is weak yes database settings
database name alles default emergency cheat nein nein es gibt ok michael 3 2 1 ok legen
wir mal was an legen wir mal was hier an internet 0w password keckel dreimal highly secure usernamen
ist blub ok so safe so wohin soll ich jetzt update a moment update a slash wohin roaming
ups update a roaming einer bin ich schon roaming key pass key pass config xml keckel da steht
kein password drin das steht kein password drin das steht der fahrt zur datenbank drin
da steht kein password da drin warum sollten da auch password drin stehen da müsste jetzt
ja dieser da wäre genau das wäre komplett unnötig da müsste ja das passwort irgendwo
drin stehen jetzt also er wäre ja auch irgendwie sinnvoll also ja ich insofern ein ein problem
hat key pass aber das hat so gut wie jeder password manager wenn die software geöffnet
ist und teile der passwörter im ram sind also entschlüsselt wurden mit dem master password
und die passwörter eingelesen wurden im ram teilweise stehen dann kann man die theoretisch
aus dem ram auslesen ja das problem hat aber jeder password manager ja deswegen ist das
hätte mich jetzt auch äußerst gewundert ne das ist natürlich nicht so
wie geht es weiter
hä warum gehen die davon aus dass niemand mehr als 20 geräte hat und der dhcp halt
von unten verteilt und mit 20 sicherlich safe ist das ist aber eine ziemliche als
himmlischer trugschluss von nintendo wenn key pass über web daf geladen wird dann könnten
die da können die dateien für den web daf zugang in der konfig stehen ja gut wenn du
in deiner web daf url irgendwie ein password drin hast ja ok bestimmt natürlich aber
aber halt nicht die von der datenbank
was für eine ultra bescheuerte advice das ist wirklich hängen geblieben das ist wirklich
richtig dumm ich mein ja irgendwann wirst du schon mal eine freie finden die sache ist
bloß die ob die dann wirklich frei ist oder nur das gerät aus weiß man ja nicht und wie
wäre es in seinen router einfach mal rein zu gucken das einfachste ist eh also die einfachste
möglichkeit ist dhcp sich das ganze ziehen lassen und dann einfach diese adresse static
also statik least zu machen und fertig das auch am einfachsten da muss man nichts einstellen
statik least und gut ist
ja nicht zwangsläufig also ja das hast du das recht das machen die das ist normalerweise
auch so aber ich glaube das hängt ein bisschen von ab was der client macht glaube der client
kann auch sagen ich will komplett mein dhcp lease releasen und ich glaube sogar dass du
theoretisch sagen kannst per dhcp ich will eine neue ip da bin ich mir aber nicht sicher
dhcp ist ja auch so eine nicht enden wollendes ding an verschiedenen sachen was du da drinne
machen kannst zumindest weiß ich selbst dass es unterschiede gibt je nachdem was anfrag
genau weil zum beispiel wenn ich mein nas starte da muss ich das entschlüsseln über
ssh mit einem password und der kriegt eine andere ip als mein nas nachdem es hochgefahren
ist und es ist die gleiche netzwerkarte ja also hat dementsprechend auch die gleiche
die gleiche mac adresse also es hängt schon ein bisschen davon ab was der client anfragt
warum der so komische dinge anfragt das habe ich noch nie überprüft die gleiche netzwerk
karte sollte in der regel die gleiche meck haben oder ja man kann die meck nahezu beliebig
ändern in einem paket aber warum
if you add oder in einem paket ist ja falsch und müsst ihr sagen in einem esernet frame
wenn man korrekt sein will aber so korrekt sind wir nicht 30 oder 40 to it ja also die
metode von nintendo ist wirklich sehr hergeblieben
aber das nintendo das nintendo probleme mit netzwerkart wundert mich nicht
das brauche man ja nicht also wenn das nintendo ordentlich macht dann kannst du löcher in
das natt machen du brauchst einfach nur einen public server über den du die verbindung
herstellen lässt das ist kein problem also das macht jedes x beliebige game mit einem
lobby system das ist überhaupt kein ding du brauchst dafür noch nicht mal du brauchst
dafür noch nicht mal quasi wirklich in dedicated server im internet du musst einfach du brauchst
einfach nur den vermittlungsserver beim verbindungsaufbau frag mich jetzt bitte nicht mal wie es aus
dem kopf funktioniert das ist was in der richtung beide clients melden sich bei dem
bei dem vermittlungsserver so das heißt beide clients haben schon mal diesen vermittlungsserver
als in ihrer verbindungstabelle ausgehend wissen also wo sie antworten hinschicken müssen
und wie ging das jetzt weiter vielleicht kriegt es einer von euch noch aus dem kopf hin so
und dann willst du ja von von einer seite auf die andere seite direkt zu genau dann überträgt
der vermittlungsserver die public ip der beiden anderen beteiligten clients die schicken
sich gegenseitig eine message diese message wird geblockt erst mal durchs natt ich habe
vergessen wie es weitergeht und dann das zweite package geht dann irgendwie das geht aber
nur wenn es über ein vermittlungsserver macht ich habe keine ahnung mehr wie das genau
funktioniert aus dem kopf es ist nicht sonderlich kompliziert wenn man sich damit beschäftigt
hat also kannst mit einem vermittlungsserver relativ einfach löcher in dein natt bohren
und das funktioniert dann oder müssten nintendo eigentlich hinkriegen auch ohne up mp und
sonst was geht wenn du vermittlungsserver mittert hast ist es relativ einfach verifizier
das aber in jedem Fall zumindest versichern dass du gehst und erfährst wie du die ip
adresse für deine konsolen in deinem router befestigen nicht einfach einfach gar nicht
diesen blödsinn von nintendo machen also wenn der mist wirklich nur so funktioniert
dann ist es ja wirklich noch mehr bullshit als gedacht hat
in
das Port vorwärts zu machen, egal was.
Also hoffentlich habt ihr heute etwas gelernt und wir sind auch enttretend von Nintendo Insanity.
Wenn euch dieses Video gefallen hat, gebt mir einen Daumen hoch und lasst mich wissen in den Kommentaren, was ihr denkt.
Auch könnt ihr vielleicht die restlichen Videos von meinem Kanal anschauen,
und wenn ihr abonnieren könnt, dann klickt auf den Bellen, um Notifikationen zu erwerben.
Diese Tage kann YouTube euch Videos nicht zeigen, auch wenn ihr abonniert habt.
Wenn ihr weitersehen wollt, dann würde ich das nächste Video empfehlen,
als ich über fünf Router-Settings gesprochen habe, die ihr wahrscheinlich ändern müsst.
...
Wisst ihr was? Er hat mich überzeugt. Das gucken wir jetzt mal schnell rein, was das sein soll.
Das interessiert mich jetzt tatsächlich. Ich rate auch gleich mal, aber vorher sag ich was zu...
Durch die Trash-Message wird ein Port offen, man muss da nur die nächste Welt anregen.
Ja, so hab ich das auch in Erinnerung.
Die Sache ist plus die, normalerweise gehören da zu einer TCP-Verbindung.
Ähm, ne Session, also ne... Wie heißt das bei TCP? So ne Transaction-Nummer.
Und wenn die nicht passt bei der Antwort, dann weiß ich nicht, wer das checkt.
Ähm, müsst plötzlich mal mit beschäftigen.
Nochmal zum langsamen Rate-Problem. Ich schreibe mit 210 MB, das ist ordentlich.
Also mein, für eine SSD geht's schneller, aber... Genau, für Westplatten ist das okay.
Wie viele hast du denn drinne?
Aber ich hab das Gefühl, dass das System sehr träge ist, ist brandneun, zehn, vier...
Also Software-Rate, also die Zugriffszeiten müsstest du mal testen.
Rate macht die Zugriffszeiten nicht unbedingt besser.
Also gerade SSDs im Rate können, was Zugriffszeiten angeht, langsamer sein als ne SSD alleine.
Aber warum ist bei dir so lahm? Ist kein Schimmer.
Zu wenig RAM. Im Zweifelsfall zu wenig RAM.
Es könnte auch sein, dass du relativ viel IO-Weight hast.
Mach mal nen DD und mach mal hier wieder deine 500G-Copy-Aktion.
Und dann guck mal nebenbei mit nem D-Stat und nem Hardtop und so, was deine CPU-Auslastung und deine Weights sagen.
Ja, also D-Stat ist da beispielsweise ganz gut für, falls ich überhaupt installiert hab.
Ja, da musst du mal nen Blick drauf haben, was so deine CPU-Usage und deine...
Moment, wo steht denn IO-Weight? Ist das nur bei Hardtop dabei?
Ja, genau, was deine Load macht und was dein Weight sagt.
Also vielleicht bringt dir das ja schon was.
Ja, dann ist das ja gar nicht so verkehrt gewesen, was ich erzählt hab.
So, wir gucken jetzt mal ganz schön. Das interessiert mich jetzt ganz schön.
Also was haben wir denn hier? Intro brauchen wir nicht. Exist the config-Menü.
Setting 1. Okay, wir überskippen das gerade mal.
Doch, du hast recht, Hardtop hat jetzt 2 Tabs oder hat jetzt mehrere Tabs, das ist relativ neu hier.
Kannste IO gucken, genau.
Ja, das ist tatsächlich richtig praktisch mittlerweile. Das gibt's doch nicht so lang, das IO-Tab.
Guck mal, das können wir bei mir auch gucken. Da mach ich mal ein komisches DD wieder.
Dann können wir mal gucken, was hier passiert.
Warum ist das jetzt auf einmal so schnell?
Bestimmt im cache.
Okay, hier siehst du es. Er ist nicht schnell. Es sieht einfach nur schneller aus.
Ja, guckt, das ist, ich muss sagen, Hardtop ist mittlerweile sehr praktisch geworden mit diesem IO-Tab.
Ich weiß, warum es nicht schneller geht. Meine CPU ist einfach mal am Anschlag, kann das?
Die CPU ist am Anschlag, deswegen kopiert das nicht schneller.
Keck, warum ist meine CPU am Anschlag?
Neue CPU?
Man muss es auch nicht mit DD machen. Man kann auch die Billig-Variante ist.
Cat DevZero und dann irgendwie nach PV und dann Pipen nach Plugpunkt binden, geht genauso.
Und wenn man ganz cool ist, wenn man ganz cool ist, dann macht man es so.
Guck mal, der ist viel schneller als mit DD. Warum das denn?
Nee, ist er gar nicht. Er schwankt, er schwankt, er schwankt.
Jetzt muss ich aber löschen das Ganze.
Kann er dir das hier chat? Was willst du von mir?
Also das ist, nur mal zur Erklärung, PV ist ein Programm, das nimmt Input an und schreibt das quasi wieder auf Standard-Out raus und misst dann einfach, was durchgeht.
So, Plugpoint bin ist das, wo der Output hinkommt und das ist der Input, dieses Input Redirection aus der Datei. Das ist die Bash-Variante.
So, Settings 1, was sollen wir an unseren Routern ändern?
Lul, zweite Setting. Einfach auslassen.
Da hat er recht. Ja, den würde ich ändern, allerdings nur, wenn man da standardmäßig den Kram vom Provider hat, was eigentlich der Fall ist, weil du kriegst deinen Provider verteilt, gib dir eine IP und gib dir auch ein DNS mit und das ist meistens der Provider-DNS.
Den Provider-DNS würde ich tatsächlich nicht verwenden, weil gerade die Telekom so Sachen macht wie Custom-Suchseiten mit Blödsinn drauf. Diese komischen Telekom-DNS-Redirection Sachen. Vergessts, Müll.
Deswegen nehmt ihr irgendwas anderes.
Das ist tatsächlich richtig.
Ja gut, das muss man nicht erzählen. So, nächster Tipp.
Ja, vielleicht, wenn man da Probleme hat. Du kannst dann quasi mehr Channels angeben, bzw. wenn du breitere Sachen hast, dann potenziell mehr übertragen kannst. Ja, aber das ist tatsächlich ganz sinnvoll.
Welchen DNS empfiehlst du? Ganz ehrlich, ich bin da relativ pragmatisch. 1.1.1.1 oder 8.8.8.8. Fertig aus.
Nächstes Tipp, nächste Tipp. Nächster Tipp, der letzte Tipp. The finally, we come to number 5, though I do have a bonus one in the end. This one is fortunately way easier to discuss and it is WiFi-protected setup or... WPS.
zu machen, um die Buzzer zu verbinden.
Das macht es einfacher, die Buzzer zu verbinden,
als die Passworte zu klicken.
Aber alles, was ich hier alles gesehen habe,
sagt, dass es sehr unbeschränkt ist.
Und du kannst mir sagen, aber ich denke nicht, dass
das ein Feature ist.
Okay, nun, dieses nächste Setup
ist ein extra Bonus, denn es sollte
bereits durch Default geblieben werden,
aber du musst dir wirklich sicher sein, dass es so ist.
Es ist ein Setup, welches die Remotes
verwendet werden soll, und du solltest
das absolut verwendet haben, wenn es nicht schon ist.
Eigentlich macht es so,
das will man natürlich nicht, das ist schon wahr.
Und ich habe dann meinen
Passwortmanager, der generiert mir das Passwort
und dann sagt die Webseite
auf einmal, äh, nö,
wir wollen kein 32
stelliges Passwort, maximal 16
Stellen.
Dabei, und das
kann man nicht oft genug sagen,
dabei ist die Passwortlänge das
Entscheidende und nicht so sehr
Sonderzeichenzahlen und so weiter.
Also ein 30 Zeichen
Passwort
aus nur kleinen Buchstaben
ist um ein viel, viel,
viel, viel, ich könnte das ganz, ganz
viel sagen, vielfach
sicherer als ein
tja, sagen wir mal,
12 oder 14 Stellen Passwort
oder, nenne mal die Hälfte, als ein
15 Stellen Passwort mit
Sonderzeichen drinne.
Das heißt, Passwortlänge zu
beschränken ist eigentlich, gut, dass man
nicht mehr als das, was in das Datenbankfeld
dann reinpasst, als, wobei es
eh egal, es wird eh kleinzeitig gehashed und
das ist eh immer gleich. Wenn nicht, würde
ich mir Gedanken machen, das macht keinen Sinn.
Es macht wirklich keinen Sinn,
die Passwortlänge zu beschränken.
Gar nicht.
Weil du speicherst in der
Datenbank ja nicht das Passwort, du speicherst
den Hash und den Zoll in der Datenbank.
Und der ist immer
gleich lang.
Also es macht überhaupt keinen
Sinn, die Passwortlänge zu beschränken.
Du könntest theoretisch einem User
auch erlauben, ein 1024
stelliges Passwort zu machen.
Ist das oft ein Anzeichen dafür, dass es nicht
gehashed ist? Nee, so weit wird...
Also ja, könnte man jetzt denken, aber so weit würde
ich wahrscheinlich gar nicht mal gehen.
Die sind einfach nur blöd
und wollen wahrscheinlich, oder was heißt blöd?
Wollen wahrscheinlich nicht, dass die Leute beim Support
anrufen, weil sie ihr 40 stelliges Passwort vergessen
haben und das zu oft passiert.
So siehts aus.
Passwortlänge ist das allerwichtigste.
Als Passwort wird ja gar nicht unsicher, wenn das einer
aufschreibt. Ein Passwort auf dem
Zettel ist immer noch um ein vielfaches
sichere als Passwort TXT auf dem Desktop.
Weil der Riesenunterschied zwischen
Passwort TXT und dem Zettel ist,
dass wenn du einen Keylogger...
Keylogger hast du eh gelitten. Wenn irgendein Typ
Remote Zugang auf dein Rechner hat,
der kann sich die Passwort TXT angucken,
aber der kann nicht bei dir in
Schrank in die Schublade gucken
auf den Zettel. Es sei denn,
es sei denn,
du hast den Zettel irgendwo auf der Erde liegen
und du hast so einen neuen Staubsaugerroboter
mit Kamera,
dann könnte der deinen
Staubsaugerroboter fernsteuern über das
Webinterface und mit der Kamera
den Zettel suchen, wo dann Passwort
drauf steht und das klauen.
Ich gebe zu, aber
ein recht unwahrscheinliches Szenario.
Deswegen mag ich übrigens auch keine Staubsaugerroboter
mit Kameras.
Exzellenz, Sixhead-Time.
Ich wusste es doch. Der Chat hat wieder die ultimative
Lösung ausgearbeitet.
Wenn du jetzt die Kamera noch fernsteuern
kannst mit dem Staubsaugerroboter,
dann hast du es wirklich durchgespielt.
Fivehead-Time ist auch nicht schlecht.
Das ist tatsächlich, das ist eine richtig
coole Idee.
G-Bait, richtig geiler G-Baiter.
Das finde ich gut.
Dann macht der, der Angreifer macht dann
wirklich sowas hier.
Genauso sieht es bei ihm aus.
Haha, der Noob. Oh, Keg-Waite.
Keg-Waite.
Ok, dann hat er wahrscheinlich als nächstes
mal den Keylogger auf dem Rechner, wenn er Zugriff
auf deine Passwort-TXD hat. Aber gut,
die Idee finde ich gut. Das hat was.
Hat was, finde ich nice.
Ok Leute, ich muss ins Bett.
Ich schreibe jetzt noch was ins
GitHub-Issue.
Ich bin irgendwie auf 600 MB,
what the fuck.
Und dann sehen wir uns morgen
wahrscheinlich.
Ich hoffe, ich habe alles beantwortet. Wenn nicht,
merkt's euch.
Und im nächsten Stream beantworte ich's.
Macht's gut. Macht's gut. Bis dann. CU.